citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for what is easily one of my most
anticipated shows of the year we are
starting up the Ahsoka Series so you use
a force to leave the like button and
John how are you I so can't wait to see
what this show is like to see what the
show is like but and Michael who
literally just got back from a flight he
is our Star Wars expert and didn't want
to start this without him thank you for
readjusting your flight plans I would
not miss it for the world you did like a
whole rewatch whole reread I did a lot
of re-watching and a lot of my first
time reading I learned how to read for
this I read that throughout books it was
my first book I ever got through so this
was an exciting thing for me well before
we go into this we got a word from a
grand Admiral sponsor hey guys it's many
of you all know I'm a big fan of G fuel
I love me some g-fuel and here's the
thing sometimes when you get re-up for
the brand most of the time they will
offer you a little bit more moolah a
little bit more money because they're
like wow you being getting so many
conversions you've been encouraged to
that audience to go get some more G fuel
we're gonna pay you a little bit more
money that's not how it operates around
here what I've decided instead was
you don't need to pay me more money
just send me a lot more G Fuel and so
that's exactly what they did
[Music]
there we go people come in here see and
I still got
this much left
to fill in for G fuel use our code
rejects to get yourself 20 off select
tops
this is all mine I'm not sharing this
anymore
oh yeah so I forgot to mention full
length Reaction watch along where you
single with your own copy of Ahsoka
series that's going to be available for
super sex we just got our patreon but
because this is the first episode it's
available for the entire public Link in
the description box and pin comments so
you can go choose that option if you
prefer let's let's get into it
oh Samurai music boy oh boy
this is refreshing
a crawl nice
evil Galactic Empire has fallen and a
new Republic has taken it to its place
however Sinister agents are already at
work to undermine the fragile peace a
plot is underway to find the lost
Imperial Grand Admiral thrawn and bring
him out of Exile once presumed Dead
rumors are spreading of thrawn's return
which would Galvanize the Imperial
remnants and start another Hua former
Jedi Knight Ahsoka Tano captured one of
thrawn's allies and learned of a secret
map which is vital to the enemy's plans
Ahsoka Now searches for the map as her
prisoner Morgan ellsbeth is transported
to the new Republic for trial I'm
surprised none of us did the Clone Wars
Voice last time on Star Wars
yes the new Republic Cruiser
so Elizabeth is your prisoner I mean
what else are you gonna do with her
after weaponer in a duel
ask them to identify themselves and
transmit their clearance code yes sir
yo the music is great so yeah this is do
you know who did it I'm not sure they're
Jedi
they say again the signal
clearance code
I want to meet these Jedi oh boy I've
got a bad feeling about this
yeah
I like how the pacing feels like it's
taking its time already it's just so
cinematic already compared to everything
else I wish it felt more like a cartoon
oh
okay row quite a surprise beating Jedi
out here on existence remains a mystery
to most Captain hail
uh some slight Qui-Gon Vibes I don't
understand
you're no Jedi no they're not should
have surrendered when the Empire
collapsed get RD3 to scan these
Impostors for identification you're all
dead to show you our identification oh
boy
there's the orange
Oh
no
you're right about one thing Captain I'm
no Jedi we are no Jedi
it feels like a reversal on a phantom
menace that's exactly it yeah it Rhymes
poetry
lady gotta fight lady
foreign
ER hallway whoa oh happy yes
wow what an introduction yeah he's
menacing
Morgan
she looks more like a witch of death
Amir more than ever right now she sure
does the Jedi who captured me seeks the
map who is this Jedi Ahsoka Tana the
God's damn right oh boy oh boy oh boy
have a card come on
I just love it it's carrying over that
Western Vibe it does feel like that
episode of forest season 2 was the pilot
for this master and Apprentice part one
instead of chapter one love it
where are we
Denver Colorado
here we go
the glyphs kind of look like uh some
stuff from fall and Order
foreign
yes
awesome awesome
she could just easily use your hands
she's like I'm gonna do this so badass
oh okay the golden snitch
you're a Jedi Ahsoka
getting some World between World Vibes
right now
[Music]
giant boulder is gonna chase her out of
there I know it yeah put put the bag of
sand on top
oh I think she just really likes this
rock I've never scratched jealous of a
rock
that was actually a really cool subtle
way of using the force
sick
I really love how deliberate this is so
far watching her study the room also
after playing Jedi Survivor for like a
thousand hours as somebody else have to
solve a puzzle for once
okay
Fifth Element multi-pass
I love this foreboding music who did
this score
[Music]
it really is that swashbuckling Vibe
where is Omega when you finally find the
treasure
already in contact with him I wonder if
she's the one that kept him safe
the crackle of tenants voice
oh here we go
hello there
sounds exactly like Kyla us
it doesn't sound exactly like Kayla
give a Droid a cape it is the coolest
thing
I have two phallic objects
kick their asses
she just Falls in neck by accident
I don't even waste her time
yes yeah
oh man
head turn
wow this is like playing Jedi Survivor
yes
thump self-destruct
[Music]
got a blast okay are they gonna blow
this all the ruins yep
where are you
great shot
holy this looks great man
no you won't keep going oh
damn
nipple chills everywhere
wow
damn destroyer of worlds
good thing I arrived when I did watch my
back that is the job of a Jedi Padawan
Lana
you have been right where Morgan said it
would be
how did you get her to tell the truth as
Morgan wanted to snatch it from you I
didn't follow standard Jedi protocol
oh wow
if it still goes by Cold filter well it
sounded like he's going by fulcrum he's
going about who Yang's going by fulcrum
affirmative
26 out
this is already better to be the
Mandalorian season three I'm also
excited to finally have some good
portrayal of the new Republic because
it's been
they did not put their dollars to waste
on this one no they did not visual
effects team did an excellent job on
this I mean I feel like I'm watching a
movie
she looks awesome general sandula
see you
cry I'm afraid we've lost your prisoner
and prepared a briefing to get you
caught up
it's like old times
I wonder if we're gonna see the little
baby Chase who are they
pose what a freeze perhaps one of them
was once a Jedi possibly
huh I'm gonna guess Balin was once a
Jedi and then she was The Apprentice
that makes sense by their age
this old man needed a mentor
star map
not just any star map
this one holds the secret Morgan's after
look at symbol the last missing Imperial
Grand Admiral thrawn which can get them
to Bridger I started hearing whispers of
his return which led me to Morgan thrawn
returned somehow and the secret is held
in that map
opportunities during the storm we're
having a little bit of an earthquake
right now
rolling hurricane earthquake
nothing is certain
except our enemies believe that they
know where to look
whoa
this reaction is more like Star Wars at
everything yeah
Disney plus plus you know who could help
you with this
I do go to Sabine I'm not sure she'll
want to help
she'll do it make her for Ezra
oh gosh I still can't believe that this
is real life
baby look at it go it's a true
Metropolis now
dude no way they got her did they get
him to play a rider again
oh my goodness
in recognition
courage
tell me he's playing Ryder here to say a
few words is one of those Rebel leaders
Commander Sabine Wren or the mural
behind the man yo
oh this feels like Rebels
Sabine ran finder now and Destroyer
oh my gosh
that's gnarly it was brought to life
all right for those that don't know
Sabine wren
this is a great introduction right here
that is awesome
oh man they literally brought the bridge
to life
feels like the opening of that JJ Abram
Star Trek movie
siberius Kirk Governor's Daddy's looking
for you oh yeah
are you missing the ceremony
oh that was today
man amazing
I can't believe they brought this to
life well they spared no expense
her helmet
what is this song
I think it's new Commander Stand Down
[Music]
is she gonna stop
nope nope Stand Down she's not stopping
[Music]
she's crazy doesn't even look like her
pulse is racing whoa
boy boy oh boy wow
recognized game
this must be that punk band from uh the
Visions episode
we'll see a lost wolf in here oh God I
hope so
[Music]
new merchandise unlocked
I already got mine on pre-order
everyone's looking to adopt a cat or
fostering five right now
a nice little subtle it's interesting
how she's become like a full-on like
there's a dissonance she's recluse well
I can't imagine it'd be easier for her
to confront what happened on Mandalore
after her friends
damn they look real animatronic
more than the others I need I need you
to understand
you left her a separate recording we've
been through a lot grew up together in
this Rebellion we're not really family
but you're like a sister to me
that's a change of town now I won't be
there to help you I'm counting on you to
see this through
May the force be with you May the force
be with you see what through I mean I
imagine it hoping to get back to
Mandalore that didn't quite pan out and
imagine her whole family was killed
she reminds me of just about everybody I
know in LA
she has a lot of presents though man an
ancient temple built by my ancestors
who the ninth sisters of death the night
sisters
they confirmed it
you're a witch
yes she is burner
a Survivor yeah
the Jedi has the map
or it was vaporized no she hasn't what
if she does you're lucky luck has
nothing to do with it Fate has decided
our next moon then it's lucky fate would
do that send this one to the planet
lothal retrieve it she can anticipate
that Ahsoka would go to Sabine
ahsokitano's former Apprentice is on the
foul you're looking for Sabine wren
he knows a little too much but how I
mean maybe he knew Ahsoka when he was
like once part of the Jedi Order yeah or
a young lane or something
this is very translator
was it just a dream is she connecting
via the force it was heavily implied
that she was force sensitive if you're
gonna piss off the World by saying that
I mean to wield the darksaber the way
she did to be The Apprentice of Ahsoka
Tana
maybe she might be
this is an interesting parallel because
Ahsoka and Sabine you know master and
Apprentice but Bale and his master they
like get along and there's such a
distance between these two so it is
telling a parallel between them
you missed the ceremony
was that yesterday
[Music]
my mind I missed Sabine everyone was
there this makes me so happy I know
hello who Yang still in one piece oh yes
still 75 original pounds super
man looking at each other
I think there is some additional stuff
that we might not know about between
these two of course
we'll handle the tension
you're going to want to hear what she
has to say
it's cool that he gets to play two
live-action characters now in the Star
Wars show that's pretty amazing right
this music is so transported it is quite
moving I gotta say
it really does help bolster the visual
language I think I know how to find Ezra
who
chives
to hear some of that familiar Star Wars
Tunes Hope Rising
when at the end of rebels she arrived at
the White staff that's already common
gone and some things happened after that
I'm pretty sure that's what's going on
yeah well you thought this might have
been an in-between then I thought this
might have been that exact moment and
just a little retcon and how they do it
oh Chopper where did you find this in a
world named Arcana
it was a stronghold for the witches of
dothamir oh wow we're getting so much to
happen here you have the artist guy tell
me what you see
who there's such tension between them
where do you call home these days
this ship serves me fine the bed with
who yang
lightsabers aren't the only thing he can
build you never made things easy for me
Master oh
clarify what that means there is nothing
easy about being a Jedi
so was training her to be a jet and I
should have made a good one she just
blocked herself got destroyed during her
training I think she blocks herself off
from the force but from her stubbornness
and I think by the end of the show
the force will be Unleashed good can I
take this
where are you going that's not good
somewhere I can think more clearly
I'm not sure that's a good idea that's a
terrible idea
why
this isn't just about finding Ezra it's
about preventing Another War you think I
don't know that
map stays here
it's not gonna stay okay
I love that Ahsoka has to deal with an
apprentice who is just as stubborn
frustrated as she was can't hold a
mirror to herself I think sometimes it's
harder to train the one that's so
similar to you construction and overall
design are executed exactly the way I
taught youngings to build a lightsaber
oh in the last 500 years I've only
known one student who built a saber such
as this damn he disappeared at the end
of the Clone Wars as many Jedi
Order 66 Survivor master and an
apprentice
it would be my assumption he took on an
apprentice after that interesting that's
interesting because they're not exactly
Sith some type of in between
it's not a gray Jedi
every time we say gray Jedi something
awful happens
let's get this video dive bombed no
dude they're gonna go right after Sabine
she would totally lose that fight oh
this is gonna be like uh Qui-Gon on his
way back to the ship on Tatooine with
Darth Maul
hello
literally exactly like it probe Droid
and everything it is poetry I mean
filoni loves Phantom Menace he sure does
this is the shot with Darth exactly the
same thing yeah
whoa good reveal dang I love how
storyboarded this feels you can really
almost like animation yeah every shot is
composed
it's interesting that the way they've
composed this because even if you
haven't seen Rebels I think they do that
like John Wick hinting at history thing
where you can still like kind of keep up
um right clearly yeah all right yeah
okay cool she took the map
off the ship when I explicitly told her
not to come on a Circa but you and I
both know
yep she's still just a stubborn and
bullish as ever
give it Eight Episodes things didn't
turn out the way either of us wanted
this is not gonna go the way you think
too soon
it's always too soon for the end of the
Clone Wars I walked away from him
I was watching the whole Jedi Order yeah
no oh you look so sad just like I walked
away from Sabine
you have commitment problems sometimes
even the right reasons have the wrong
consequences
poignant Ends don't justify the means I
feel like she has every reason to fear
miss training an apprentice after her
master became you know
hey there you go
it's a Rubik's Cube
oh
and it has three faces oh sick
wow they're doing this all in one shot
that is so that is so cool yeah awesome
cool
yo
oh and this is right when that girl's
gonna show up actually
whoa
he's right there interestingly enough
that looked like a different galaxy a
galaxies are farther away yeah
take it we're gonna take the loath cat
hey sneaky
kick its ass
how do your elbows handle this
smash against metal
oh God oh God
[Music]
oh smart oh yeah
they're still talking
helmet helmet do it
no lightsaber yo yeah
she's gonna totally lose this fight
though we've been
just gonna she's gonna get owned
it feels like a samurai duel
what about Star Wars has it anyways
oh all right
[Music]
this fight does feel kind of like Kendo
like a felony doesn't adopt the pretty
cool fighting
oh she is they're both just trying to
study each other
oh dang
oh here it is
okay
ah she's just toying with Sabine
that's exactly it yeah
dude oh so it was gonna happen right now
whoa so many badass cross saber shots
there
[Music]
I see them this is literally Phantom
Menace I feel like sabine's gonna get
stabbed
if you lose a limb
oh
come on
[Music]
whoa
wow
and then they killed off Sabine wren
did not return somehow
oh
[Applause]
it's very present
well done Dana e gloverman Kevin keiner
he did uh Rebels sure did
Wowie
that makes a lot of sense oh it's the
pergil so the first time in a long time
that Star Wars visual effects in
television is doesn't feel like it's
just on a volume that's exactly it now
this felt I was
I was immersed yeah
like they probably did do a lot of
volume but they sold it really well oh
yeah with physical elements yeah I I
genuinely love that I was in love with
that it was he played writer right
yeah okay that's so cool if you got okay
for you guys who don't know Clancy Brown
played writer in Star Wars Rebels and to
see him get to actually as everyone else
has been recast right everyone else yeah
everyone
and Chopper and Chopper
but to see him it pop back up and after
he already was in uh Mandalorian as as
uh it was in that Bill Burr episode as
one of the villains and I think that was
the Rick Family episode of season one
wow that was a great episode yeah uh and
um yeah he's one of the most prolific
voice actors out there he's just a great
like real life actor too so it's so cool
to see him actually yeah that translated
so well uh and there's just so many
beautiful little touches the time spent
on lethal and just seeing that come to
life I mean it really was
they captured it perfectly yeah I loved
how meditative this was and and how like
it was emotional yet cold you know and
and I think they're gonna be arcing into
something that does feel either more
hopeful or more harrowing like you
really don't know which direction will
go because it's a it's supposed to be
setting up some stuff right uh for
whatever that filoni crossover the
felony verse which is what this is and
this is the first time felony got to
actually Helm the pilot like literally
setting the stage for everything that's
to come and while I thought that episode
of Mandalorian season two which
reintroduced Ahsoka it that felt like
the backdoor pilot for this in every way
concerning that you got Elizabeth you're
picking up with right away the
confirmation that she's a witch of
dathomir
um who if you guys like play Jedi fall
in order or you know obviously Clone
Wars you'd be familiar with her the plan
where Darth Maul is from yeah and um
then and Savage Savage Ventress Opress
no savage oh wait no
waitress Adventures yeah yeah oh Savage
yeah I got my names
the ill-fated brother the brother of all
yeah
um yeah are they really a massage yeah
that's where I got confused here yeah
a lot of names out there there are a
couple names in Star Wars um but I loved
it man uh I I thought this was the right
tone and this is what uh I I hoped it
would be I do wonder if some people
might find it boring though you know if
they're
I I think there can be a bit of a disc
because it's weird I mean I'm excited to
hear what you think because
um he doesn't care what I think I know
it's just I think it'll be really easy
for us to get wrapped up in like Rebels
talking all that stuff so uh whereas if
you a lot of people didn't see Rebels
I wonder if they'll be felt that they'll
be left at a distance you know
um but would you so yeah what'd you
think so far Michael well
interestingly enough I feel like these
first two episodes are likely going to
be the most of the feeding that like the
love of rebels and and I think some of
the later episodes particular as
particularly I mean when Ahsoka even
when her master was referenced the way
her face changed like Anakin's Force
ghost is around at this point right have
they talked have they had that
conversation yet I mean I think there's
going to be a lot of unpacking there
um and for me like having just finished
the thrawn books and the comics
there is something that like Rebels fans
are I don't think even prepared for
unless they've read the books and
admittedly even having read the books I
don't think I'm prepared for what they
have cooking up here
um but in terms of pace I'm glad this
was a slow burn I mean I was I was on
the edge of my seat the entire time it
felt
genuinely cinematic which is something
that Star Wars television there was some
episodes of the Mandalorian that knocked
that out of the park and other episodes
where I'm like what is lizzo doing here
yeah
um certainly not forcing anybody out of
their comfort zone yeah I'll tell you
that much yeah but I loved it and uh
honestly I hate that we're even talking
right now because I want to watch The
Next Step I know yeah I know people are
just like get to the next one they
released they released two for a reason
yeah yeah yeah you're like oh you're
that's why I'm trying not to become a
prognosticator for what's going to come
next because I'm like what's the point
we're gonna watch the second episode
then we prognosticated a good ass vocab
word damn that's good that's a t word
yeah yeah no I mean I looked it up
beforehand so I could use it in this
video because of every video I've
touched Lord
for every video it'll be like just
implement it somehow hey that's a good
technique
you'll have at least 365 new words at
the end of the year uh no I mean this
was really thrilling like like having
only a mild amount of familiarity with
what Rebels is tone wise and Ensemble
wise and stuff like this gave me the
joys of both
how do I how do I put it this this felt
like the sort of fun adventure that you
get from a Mandalorian but with like the
focus that a lot of people complain is
missing from that and I feel like this
also everybody points to and or is like
the second coming of Star Wars in a lot
of ways it's certainly
earns that argument but I thought this
did nicely to pull the kind of quiet
character Nuance from Andor and then put
it in something that still feels like
it's going to be propulsive and about
Adventure
um but also contained within just a lot
of character relationships and growth
and frictions and history over time and
yeah not having all of that context I
could feel it all through the
performances and I think it was really
smart for them to give you so many
moments and scenes to introduce each
character to put them in their element
to show them breaking things down or
being rebellious or whatever it is kind
of drawing the spirits like everybody is
very clear at the moment to me even
though we haven't spent time with like
the classic Rebels Ensemble all together
much yet
um yeah this had a constant sense of
momentum and tension the Sith characters
or the you know in between Jedi Sith
whatever these new Balin and Co are
gonna be their lightsabers are orange
yeah so there's something in between
yeah
what does it mean it is I'll tell you
what it means
this is the connective tissue
between all of it and I feel like an
orange is the color and orange is the
color of connective tissue have you ever
cut somebody open before no uh
come on uh I it's all orange
it is
it's disgusting
um I
am particularly eager and excited to see
how like everything that we've seen so
far in just one episode is what I think
we were all praying for when the force
awakens came out we wanted that like
questionable what happens when the Jedi
Order is no more is there something in
between we wanted to be able to tap into
the the mystical nature of the force
have that connective tissue to the
prequels to the original trilogy but
also set up something big and exciting
and the most important part and what I
think they failed at in the sequel
Trilogy is something original something
different and like Obi-Wan too I feel
like you have that hope of like you know
here is what what do you do in the No
Man's Land Between You Know One
establishment in another one order and
another and we didn't really
rise quite to that occasion I agree yeah
yeah there's a nice mystery and suspense
to this and there's I thought what was
really smart I think it's really really
smart uh to have this established
dynamic between Ahsoka and Sabine
that way you can give a character Arc
especially for a variety of factors yeah
one being that when Ahsoka was
reintroduced in live action with
Mandalorian and her little parents and
book of Boba Fett that
but that portrayal is someone who's just
so wise and sage and she's got
everything under control yeah yeah
exactly a little too perfect exactly
which is great for like in a an
appearance a guest star appearance but
if she's going to be the lead you need
to uh throw her into something where
they can be an emotional obstacle a
hurdle for her to overcome and for it to
be something that is mirroring her past
trajectory of someone who was stubborn
and difficult to deal with and then her
even acknowledging like hey I abandoned
stuff you know I I left I got
disillusioned by the Jedi Order I left
that behind yeah I mean there's a lot of
context there that I love how they
they're smart in the way they do it
because there's such a story line in the
Clone Wars of why she left the Jedi
Order that when you watch it it's it's
not like she just left the Jedi Order it
was so it is is the whole thing like
being framed and all this stuff I mean
or left her yeah exactly there's this
whole thing to it so it's not just she
left the Jedi order but they didn't have
to make a brief because they don't have
time to dive into all that right
the level of responsibility though that
must be on her shoulders I mean even if
you don't watch all the Clone Wars to
watch the final two seasons and
particularly how they connect
ahsoka's final Arc there yeah I mean
she's living with a heavy burden right
and a lot of this is about also not
repeating the sins of the not repeating
the mistakes from the past that she's
trying to do so they've established a
good Arc for her to go down and then of
course for Sabine as well and I did yeah
because she's a really complex character
too I thought she should have been the
leader of rebels I mean well yeah she
she should have been and I think towards
the end she was getting there
um but you have to consider the fact
that like she created a weapon that
played a big role in the destruction of
her people like she has not had an easy
go of it based upon where we are in the
timeline
Mandalore is gone which means her
family's been vaporized exactly like
um I didn't even think about that and
and I I think that's probably
the other thing is if she became
ahsoka's Apprentice she would have been
pretty old at the time to become an
apprentice and historically speaking
that doesn't always work out the way you
want it to all the rules are thrown out
the window at this point man well uh no
I I don't I don't disagree with that but
it comes with its own set of challenges
um but either way there's only one real
way to figure out what happens next yeah
and that's to like And subscribe
more so than watching the next episode
like And subscribe yeah click the
notification Bell
um yeah alrighty guys well I thought uh
this was excellent and I I hope that
people latch onto the show
um especially if you're not familiar
with I don't feel I don't get the
impression you need to I think it's easy
to feel lost like there I can imagine
there will still be that camp that's
like but I think that's good
and it does I think increase the
motivation probably for then people if
they do latch onto this to go check out
the extended media because then they
will have instead of feeling overwhelmed
by like there's so many seasons and so
many characters I have like a point of
reference now to go and look for in
those pieces but they don't craft the
dialogue in a way that's like wink you
know well no it still sounds very lived
in and this is the exchange that they
would have with each other it does it's
not just Exposition City it's not just
Easter egg city either one somebody
pointed out that in the advertising they
haven't leaned at all on any of the
animated footage so they're not telling
they're not cueing the audience like you
gotta go familiarize yourself with that
otherwise you're not gonna get this at
all but it doesn't like again like from
outside a little bit of that giant well
sure there are definitely going to be
things that go over your head but those
things don't feel like you're being left
out of the club or like you know you're
lesser for not knowing but if if you
have watched other live-action Star Wars
at this point you know a majority of the
people on that mural yeah you know with
the exception of Kanan and Ezra you
don't think Force ghost Canyon will show
up no how would he have learned to
become a Force ghost
what do you mean you have to learn to
become that's not how the force works
that matters you could throw it out the
window at this point had to well for he
wasn't able to get like a physical form
at first
he could have learned something that's a
mumbo jumbo into a ghost in a few years
or he's in the wolf right he isn't a
wolf he's in the wall that I that I
believe mostly because Dave filoni has a
thing for wolves well he's got one of
those wolf t-shirts wolf just shows up
you're just like I'm doom
man I remember just being on the
internet trying to figure out what the
hell was going on with those wolves when
I was
watching Rebels I hope it saves the day
again all right let's watch second
episode let's do it let's do it all
right thanks guys for being here and um
yeah let's get to it
[Music]